joining me now exclusively is the man
who moderated DeSantis 2024 launch
tonight on Twitter David sacks he's also
the partner at craft Ventures and
co-host of the all in podcast a big
entrepreneur David great to see you
tonight um thanks for joining us now
we're going to get to Governor
desantis's Vision especially like
ripping apart the bureaucracy in a
moment but the question on everyone's
mind including my daughters tonight is
what happened I mean you handled it so
well much better than I would have but
what happened at the top
well what what happened at the top Laura
is just we had a million people
simultaneously trying to get into a
Twitter space which is an online room
and I mean DeSantis just melted the
servers we had so much interest I mean I
got to hand it to him normally it takes
a Kardashian to do that uh so we just
had so much interest it took about 15
minutes we've never had that level of
scale before on Twitter I think the
biggest room's been around a hundred
thousand and so after about 15 minutes
we just moved the room to my account
from elon's account and then it really
worked perfectly I think if your viewers
want to go on Twitter the the recording
is going viral right now they're going
to wonder what all the fuss is about
because once we got started the audio
was perfect and I think the governor was
totally unflappable and I think one
thing we you know I learned about him
from this is that once we did get
started and we were you know about 15 20
minutes late uh there was no hint of
anger or irritation on his part he was
in a great mood uh he didn't he was like
I said cool and unflappable uh you know
really I think made a great impression
as someone who doesn't get thrown off
his game for very easily no he certainly
doesn't and again other people would
have been really unhappy it's this kind
of thing has happened to me a lot David
so I'm kind of laughing because I'm very
empathetic when this kind of stuff
happens I'm glad it happens to Elon Musk
because he's a lot smarter than a lot of
people like me on technology let's talk
about the economy because that was one
issue that I and I've mentioned this
with Newt earlier you probably missed it
but why wasn't more of a focus tonight
on the issue the number one issue that
Americans say is bothering them which is
inflation high prices in the economy
I mean you're right we should have had
more questions on that there's so many
other questions that we could have
gotten to but the time just went by so
fast we only had about an hour and uh
you know I I wanted to give him time to
First lay out his vision and he did that
at the top and then we got into some of
these controversies that have been
surrounding him I asked him about this
NAACP travel advisory I asked him about
Disney we asked him about the the book
bands because there's a lot of people
out in the country who have heard all
these narratives in the mainstream media
and they've never heard directly from
him on these issues and so I wanted to
give him the chance to respond to those
things and then you know we talked about
major issues like immigration we talked
about education uh there were a lot of
issues that we did talk about I I think
it's fair maybe we should have talked
more about the economy but we also
talked about you know what a great I
think economy the State of Florida has
and there's going to be opportunities
for more of these Town Halls so you know
we'll we'll get to it next time David
can you give us a sense of the room
because we were all dying to like were
you guys together like was was Elon Musk
even there was he in like Europe I mean
we didn't know where anybody was oh no
Elon and I were together in a conference
room and Twitter headquarters and there
were a bunch of Engineers uh gathered
around us and again it's because we've
never had an event like this on social
media where you've got literally a
million plus people trying to break down
the doors to get into a Twitter space
and the only way to really test the
scalability of a tech platform is you
just get to that next level of scale and
so we had Engineers there who are
helping us out and we just made the
switch to my account and then it like I
said it worked perfectly but it was me
and Elon staying next to each other and
we were just we tried using his phone we
tried using my phone and it worked out
great so uh DeSantis was in I think
Florida and um so this is the magic of a
of a Twitter space is that everyone can
be in different places that was fun
because we had no idea where anyone was
we wanted photos of all of you but you
know we got none of that
quickly Ukraine was
it you know I care about a lot because
you know I'm I'm kind of against all
these wars of choice and I think we're
blowing a lot of money and not sure what
we're gonna get out of it in the end but
what about if DeSantis wins what do you
think is going to happen on that score
well I'm 100 with you I mean I think
Ukraine is a proxy war of choice I don't
think we should be in wars of choice I
think it's so dangerous to be in an
escalatory spiral with Russia which has
thousands of nuclear weapons what I've
heard to Santa say about this issue is
that what's happening in Ukraine is not
does not rise the level of a vital
American interest and we should be
trying to achieve a ceasefire so you
know my take on it is that where
DeSantis is is that uh is that he would
work to achieve a ceasefire as president
whereas my sense of that Biden just
keeps trying to ratchet this up and
escalate this thing so I think I'm with
you on this Laura all right David we
really enjoyed it thank you so much for
joining us I know you must be exhausted
I hope you go have a tequila shot after
that that was that was that was fun come
back soon thanks so much